I am married to somebody who lives on
YouTube anything in the house that needs
to be fixed my husband has YouTube day
I'm on Instagram a lot that's where I
hang out when I first really leverage
social media I was using Facebook groups
and I think that's where I made like my
first half a million I had all kind of
resistance to starting a YouTube channel
to be totally honest with you I was like
yeah but you had to like start YouTube
10 years ago to really have a thriving
Challenge and so finally we hired a
YouTube manager and she's like Kristen
we are taking your podcast on YouTube
and I was resistance because I'm like
but I like having my messy bun and no
makeup and recording my podcast in my
pajamas and now I have to prepare
however we are already seeing the
benefits because I'm not a consumer of
YouTube very much so therefore that's my
own bias and we tend to see the world as
we do so I'm like well I'm not on
YouTube very much who else is on YouTube
however